望遠鏡から大型ハドロン衝突型加速器まで、
新しい科学的ツールが登場するたびに、私たちが
科学者として、そして
好奇心ある人間として問える問いが刷新されてきました。
高性能 computing、すなわち HPC は
1960年代にその精鋭の仲間入りを果たしました。今日、
quantum computer は同じ扉をノックしています。
ようこそ。私の名前は Conducive to Coffee です。
IBM quantum のソフトウェアエンジニアです。
このコースでは、学生の皆さんや
専門家の方々に、quantum computing がいかに
HPC インフラと連携して
計算能力を発揮するかをお伝えすることを目指しています。
quantum と
classical computer がどのように通信しデータを交換するか、
両種類のハードウェアを活用するプログラムの書き方、
そしてこの統合が今日解決できる新たなアプリケーションを開くかを学びます。
実際の quantum ハードウェアと
classical 高性能 computing クラスタでの実践経験を積み、
従来の HPC ワークロードと並行して quantum ジョブを実行し、
結果を自信を持って解釈できるようになります。
また、quantum アクセラレーションが
本当に計算の助けになる場面と、
そうでない場面も見極められます。何より、
コンピューターの未来がどこへ向かうのか、
そこへ至るロードマップを理解できるようになります。このコースは
重要かつ
時機を得たものだと思っており、
この技術の組み合わせが
計算上の優位性を達成するために不可欠になると信じています。
これは幅広い産業に大きな影響をもたらす可能性があります。
例えば化学分野では、
より迅速な創薬や材料研究を可能にし、
金融分野では
より高度なリスクモデルや
不正検出、人工知能や機械学習では
モデルの最適化が期待されます。このコースでは、
computing リソース、
プログラミングモデル、そして quantum アルゴリズムを
深く掘り下げていきます。
ようこそ、多くのことを学びましょう。